so meine Damen und Herren Schulden sind
der neue Trend schon 2021 waren über 6
Millionen Deutsche überschuldet und
jetzt bei den Energiepreisen werden es
garantiert mehr nicht zuletzt dank
Onlineshopping nie war es so leicht und
so sexy sich im Netz zu verschulden bei
now pay later da vergisst man gerne dass
later pain im immer noch pain ist von
diesem Phänomen Leben zum Beispiel
PayPal die schwedische Firma Klarna
after pay oder unser ohne Vorkasse kommt
was zu mir nach Hause und über alles
andere denke ich halt later nach zumal
die Werbespots jetzt auch nicht direkt
Kredit schreien wenn ich mir nur mal zum
Beispiel diesen original Klarna Spot
angucke da sehe ich Wackelpudding
irgendwie geil das ist totaler Käse hier
wird irgendein Köter geföhnt noch mehr
Käse dann schlittert eine Forelle in die
Schuldenfalle Motto how much is the fish
und das heißt kleiner
smooth payments
falls ihr gerade erst reingesetzt haben
keine Sorge das hier ist nicht Aspekte
alles muss
über Schulden in dem Spot Klarna der
zweit wertvollste finanztech-konzern der
Welt versucht übrigens gerade mit ja
etwas verbesserten Konditionen für
Ratenzahlung einer möglichen Regulierung
zuvorzukommen und gelobt mehr
Transparenz höchste Zeit denn es sind ja
vor allem junge Menschen die für bei now
pay later empfänglich sind
sowie Ratenzahlungen in erster Linie im
Kunden anspricht die sich ein bestimmtes
Produkt eigentlich nicht leisten können
von Mahngebühren und Zinsen mal ganz zu
schweigen die Banken machten es ihm
zusätzlich einfach und gaben ungefragt
Dispokredite von 500 Euro und mehr an
jemanden der 700 Euro im Monat verdient
am Ende hat der Auszubildende sieben
konnten drei davon nur für das
Internet-Shopping
Textaufgabe wenn ich null Euro auf drei
Konten verteile wie viel Geld habe ich
dann insgesamt ja es ist leicht über
sowas zu lachen aber es liegt eben auch
am Geschäftsmodell der Online-Händler
niederschwellig kaufen heißt das
Zauberwort ohne Vorkasse Studien aus den
USA belegen dass sich Online-Käufer viel
stärker Verschulden wenn sie in Raten
zahlen dürfen und Corona hat es nicht
besser gemacht dann haben wir alle
gelernt wie schön shoppen vom Sofa aus
ist es hat uns quasi evolutionär
verändert könnte man sagen
Klarna und Co übernehmen für
Online-Händler dabei den schmutzigen
part das Geld eintreiben zum Teil erst
30 Tage später wie bei Paypal einer
Firma die genau weiß wie wir doofen
ticken denn Kunden erwarten dass Ihnen
alle verfügbaren Zahlungsoptionen
angezeigt werden und geben mit höherer
Wahrscheinlichkeit auch mehr bei ihnen
aus
denn eure Schulden sind unser Gewinn ihr
loser ja bei tiktok gibt es schon den
Hashtag Klarna Schulden wo junge
Online-Shopper mal erzählen wie tief sie
im Minus sind und wie das war als sie
nach drei Mahnungen den Inkassodienst
der alten klarna-schweden kennengelernt
haben ja nicht mehr ganz so smooth man
muss schon wissen dass es die Wahrheit
was in den Geschäftsbedingungen drin
steht und vielleicht sollte man einigen
tiktokern auch nochmal das ganze Prinzip
kaufen erklären ich versuche es mal hey
du männlicher Teenager am Laptop ja leg
mal kurz eine Youporn Pause ein wenn du
dir gleich aus Langeweile die geilen
Sneaker bestellst die exakt so aussehen
wie die 300 bar die du Dödel dir sowies
geholt hast musst du dafür regelrecht
Achtung bezahlen und wenn unter dem
Käsemauken Behälter die Zahl 189 steht
wie viel Geld brauchst du denn wohl um
die kaufen zu können Jerome komm schon
rum das schaffst du unter dem Schuh
steht 189 wie viel brauchst du
ah nee jetzt fängt er schon wieder an
sich einen zu rubbeln gibt's doch gar
nicht
gut Onanie ist wenigstens umsonst
experten fordern schon lange dass in
unseren Schulen Finanzkompetenz gelehrt
wird Grundkurs Zinsen bei einem
klarna-kredit von 500 Euro über 12
Monate zum Beispiel beträgt der
effektive Jahreszins
14,79%. das ist viel und ganz wichtig
wer schon total verschuldet ist sucht
sich dringend Hilfe aber bitte nicht bei
tik tok wir haben teilweise auf tiktok
dann auch schon Werbung gesehen von
bestimmten Schuldnerberatern die gegen
Geld arbeiten und die auch wieder mit
Ihrer Werbung betont junge Erwachsene
ansprechen natürlich nimm dir jetzt
einen Kredit um den tiktok
Schuldenberater zu bezahlen oder wir
schaffen tiktok ab wer auch eine Idee
wie gesagt junge Menschen brauchen mehr
Finanzkompetenz und da kann man gar
nicht früh genug ansetzen
jetzt neu der Klarna Kaufladen für
kleine konsumjunkies die mehr haben
wollen als Sie sich leisten können
ich habe ein problem
nimm dir was du willst und bezahlt was
später cool genau cool der Klarna
Kaufladen shoppen ohne Reue
[Musik]
ein paar Wochen ohne Reue jedenfalls
denn dann kommt der kleine Kaufmann zu
dir nach Hause begleitet von einem
echten inkassoeintreiber so letzte
Mahnung du sollst mir jetzt genau 924 €
eine Lektion fürs Leben der Klarna
Kaufladen jetzt bestellen deine Eltern
zahlen 14 Tage später
ach ja sie werden so schnell
privatinsolvent vielleicht sollten wir
es machen wie die Briten bei denen gibt
es bald schärfere Vorgaben für beinau
payeta-kredite Firmen müssen dann
sogenannte
erschwinglichkeitsprüfung vornehmen
bevor Sie welche vergeben was wir
definitiv nicht brauchen sind noch mehr
youtube-tutorials wie das von dieser
Flagge
[Musik]
Lisas happy schuldenblog
hi Leute okay ganz wichtig Kaufsucht
ist eine Krankheit aber die
Online-Händler wissen ganz genau wie sie
uns triggern müssen mit Rabatten oder
scheinbarer Verknappung was nur noch 500
Hobel schuld ist unser Doris Gehirn beim
Shoppen wird nämlich Dopamin freigesetzt
aber je öfter man was kauft desto kürzer
ist der glückshormonkrieg
[Musik]
aber wo Du gerade hier bist
so die Klamotten gehen alle retour ihr
die auch noch den scheiße aus ich war
besoffen als ich die bestellt habe
klar ich weiß retouren sind
riesenproblems schlechtes Klima
Wissenschaftler haben berechnet dass
durch die Rücksendungen jährlich so viel
CO2 freigesetzt wird als wenn täglich
2000 Autofahrer von Hamburg nach Moskau
fahren ja ist echt schlimm aber zum
Glück fahren ja keine Autos mehr von
Hamburg nach Moskau ich kann also
endlich
wieder Schulden machen war für mich
immer voll das große Problem aber jetzt
lerne ich von Deutschlands größten
Ökonomen
Christian Lindner ich habe mir früher
immer total den Kopf gemacht wo Chris
jetzt Geld her wurde doch so pleite bist
verleiht mir noch was
wir leihen uns Geld
aus der Zukunft und ich dumme Kuh habe
mir immer was in der Gegenwart geliehen
kommt ja nicht funktionieren ab jetzt
arbeite ich für die Profis Lindner ist
ein gottverdammte Genie keine Angst ich
will gar nicht viel der Sparkasse ich
will einfach nur die gleichen
Konditionen der Christian auch kriegt
das ist kein Minus das ist ein sonder
Fall blöder geiziger Arsch echt ey aber
wollte ich nur 100 Milliarden
ich habe die coole eh schon verballert
genau wie der Lindner beinau Palace
übrigens meine Zweitwagen Sky oder etwa
15 Millionen Essen gekostet aber den
Duftbaum gab es umsonst dazu gratis im
Prinzip habe ich also Gewinn gemacht
hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den Kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen Dank
[Musik]